happy monday reject nation we're gonna
watch the trailer today for the untold
story of d.b
cooper mr john humphrey how was your
easter did you do the traditional
humphrey tradition where you guys fly to
israel
do an easter egg hunt and whoever gets
the proper key leads you to the tomb
where jesus was resurrected
is that what you guys did and then you
got back here five in the morning
to come watch the loki trailer wow that
is dedication that's what we did
i think i might have done it in a dream
and skipped all the real parts of
in just came here but you know either
way it was it was easter
sunday took place somehow
i know what this place is the tva
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns playing their parts
to perfection
a little metaphor guy i love it makes
you sound super smart
i haven't smoked i know okay okay
he likes his cat verify this is
everything you've ever said ah no the
documents would be longer than that
yeah it's loki
that's way too short should be filing
you picked up the cabinets breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
i need your unique low-key perspective
low-key well good fun good pun
rock's covered
[Music]
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
of your entire life you've literally
stabbed people on the back like 50.
[Applause]
again
[Applause]
yes wow oh wow
cool you know
that is just a damn good trailer yeah
i mean come on guys you'd not be excited
for that
that was so good i cannot wait
and i hear this is one where they lied
to us and there will be a season two so
oh really yeah yeah apparently did you
learn that on your trip
in israel i did i spoke to an old wise
prophet who knew a lot about the mcu
what the hell is the return of our lord
and savior
you know what i'm loving about owen
wilson being in here
he's done so much work with wes anderson
every scene that he's in he's playing
mobius every scene that he's in
feels like it's out of a wes anderson
performance right
you got that quirky sort of
matter-of-factness that would be
certainly in at home in a west anderson
joint well even
the odd way they choose to like frame
kind of the tone of the scenes that he's
in you know
like there's something kind of quirky
about whenever you're with him there's
like a certain sense that they're at
odds in a way that seems like it's
permeating the tone and the style of the
scene with a certain level of like
awkward but human humor yeah yeah yeah
from what we're getting in the trailer
at least when mobius is showing
loki the ropes and showing like the
timeline of everything loki's done that
they'll probably get around to the point
where like hey if you follow
all the timeline before meddling with it
even more you would have died
at literally died at the hands of thanos
right
this is the new timeline that you've
started but now there's a
crazy ripple effect where we got to go
and fix everything and
i remember in the last trailer how you
know there were shots i'm sure if we
skim through here long enough we'll
probably find something that looks like
lady loki that people will mistake for
black widow
right that's what happened last time
yeah and uh i don't know i'm kind of
just going
actually wait was that it you know what
here's an easier way to do i'm just
going to go to the commons there's got
to be something
just keep looking at it
oh here we go j sub romanian 206
god of mischief chillin romanov right
there okay let's see here
yes exactly the moment that i thought it
would be
let's count on those timestamps yes out
of all the times i've heard that people
are saying black widow's
in the trailer but then it's been
corrected that that is most likely
actually lady loki not
a black widow i mean yeah i could see if
you see this moment this can definitely
look like the planet vermeer and it
looks like natasha
i don't know that's also not natasha's
hair
from the time she was in vormer so i'm
pretty sure this is ladies
i feel like the person they're hiding is
lady loki uh the most because i think
lady loki will probably be the person
who loki
is indeed hunting down in this series
well i gotta imagine too that they are
probably just fine with people mistaking
it for black widow because that just
generates more hype a for black widow
and b it throws people further off
creates more opportunity for the
surprise
so keep on commenting about to natasha
being in the trailer
i'm really wondering how the series will
end though jhumps because
from the looks of things loki will agree
reluctantly at first but i think like
the whole time he's going to be trying
to
meddle his way out i mean there's even
clear shots in here
that you have of loki running away and
owen wilson is chasing after him yeah
he's going to be doing his best to break
away
from having to be under the authority of
the tva
but if i'm like where where where does
this go with loki after this like how
will this segway into thor love and
thunder yeah i mean i have to imagine it
would have
something to do with that and this is
the loki who
you know was about to swipe the
tesseract and that version of loki is
you know at least still
on the thanos uh train at that moment
right so yeah
no no no no i can't get the money but
yeah like it seems like that also has a
motivational level of
more mischief more villainy so it makes
me wonder what degree
of character arc they're gonna give to
him and whether we are going to see him
also turn into
the main timeline loki became more of a
benevolent character over time and i
kind of imagine that you know
having a show surrounding loki will want
to
like they can't make him too much of a
villain you know to have his own show i
mean although he has to
maintain some of that mischief so that's
the big question for me and i wonder him
trying to break out is that going to be
early on and then he finally learns to
kind of
accept the purpose of the tva and work
with them or is this going to be the
kind of thing where he gets there and
immediately every episode is just like
how do i get out of here how do i get
yes
increasingly interesting ways or
something like that well
in the same way how the flash new movie
is gonna be opening up the multiverse
for dc films i think loki
will be the true game changer some
people thought it'd be one division
that'd be doing it right in my mind
from at least how it appears it's
actually going to be loki
that will be the one that opens up the
alternate timelines the most like
end game introduced this segway off of
this character from loki
this loki version from endgame going
into here where it's very apparent that
you'll probably be looking at alternate
realities and alternate timelines
of you know moments that we've seen
before like you do have that one shot
here where that is the avengers
tower destroyed so maybe this is during
a version of
events where thanos won or maybe this is
during the blip period
it could be that it seems like the one
thing that the shows have been dealing
with especially falcon the winter
soldier has been
events uh during the blip this loki was
never exposed to that
you know and i'm sure there'll be
channels more like you know canadian
land or new rock stars who do a great
job at breaking down specifically where
a lot of these more
mystical locations more godlike
locations are
there are moments that look like he's
returning to asgard and there was
probably like
other planets or other parts of the
mythology that you know we haven't been
yet introduced to but it looks like it's
kind of going back to some moments kind
of
look like with the way they're composed
in their angles of the kenneth brauna
days of doors
and things like that hey and i mean
that's kind of a neat thing to do
because that is one of the more visually
distinct
movies and it introduced us to loki so
why not i gotta say
the music in this trailer i love the
orchestral cinematic
string music that we have here it's from
the composer named natalie holt
and from what i'm seeing i don't see
that she's worked on
any mcu films or properties before so
this would be your first time being here
and blood and i i love the tune and
music is
freaking awesome yeah and that's one
thing you know marvel could i mean
there's some great uh motifs and some
great moments in marvel scores but i
feel like that is one thing that over
time people pointed out it's like man
these scores could be
even crazier and so if they're branching
out that's exciting
all right guys well the loki official
trailer what did you guys think are you
excited for the god of mischief to
continue being mischievous leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
and
last but not least
as promised last month we got it on the
day of and
it's funny because he constantly points
out how it's always on properties that
he's very much into whenever we do give
him a shout out and it's his birthday
today
flev dorit happy birthday to you dude i
know last month we did a very sarcastic
shout out this time will be very sincere
for you
you got a greater
you're a great guy man guys you're a
cheerful
and benevolent fellow you bring me lots
of joy you've been an amazing
contribution to us as an emotional and
mental support you've been there for us
so
i hope that today you are able to do
something
even if it's a little thing something at
all where you feel like you can truly
celebrate and just have a great time
because you absolutely deserve it i hope
that you have a
chance to have an encounter youtube's
been cracking down on some certain
commentary lately you know
put your uh find a woman
yes
enjoy yourself touch yourself let's get
down to business
send us a video